what was it a month ago we had Bob
nightingale on USA Today baseball
columnist and didn't he say at the time
it's done deal Bryce Harper is going to
the fillings Bob Nightingale joining us
from the winter baseball meetings in Las
Vegas he joins us where are you right
now Bob my hotel room just left early
morning in the casinos in ready to work
Charlie Moynihan the legendary ESPN
producer so he's down in the casino from
last night is that right you're a great
reporter Bob okay
months ago you said Bryce Harper done
deal going to Philadelphia still feel
that way and still think the something
ends up that way your goggle white sox
are gonna be bidding big time okay I
don't think they go much over 300
million the Dodgers are kind of dark
horse I don't think they don't go that
kind of level but they are interested
you know I think that's probably his
first choice being a Las Vegas guy but I
still think that Philadelphia will
easily have a high bid and do everything
possible to get him and it feels like
for Scott Boras he usually sends his
client to the highest bidder is that
fair to say with with the splash that he
loves to make yeah I mean last time I
can remember one of Scott's clients
leaving money table was when Greg Maddux
turned on the Yankees and with Atlanta
Braves that was just over a what eight
million dollar difference yeah but
Maddux is a different cat he wasn't he
wasn't made for New York and Atlanta
suited him a whole lot better
personality wise but I wonder about that
with Bryce Harper is there is there too
big of a spotlight for him or does he
love that spotlight that he's not afraid
to be the highest-paid player and to go
into a tough market like Philadelphia or
you know go out and play for the Dodgers
yeah no I think it loves that about like
you know thrives are that I mean Dodgers
you know such a you know I kind of
franchise everything else close to home
I just can't see if someone's offering
you it you know 10 or 12 year contract
in going to a place like LA in five
years it just seems like
too big of a risk you leave your way to
make some money on the table all right
Manny Machado
did he talk himself out of that big
contract with some of these teams by
saying that he's done a Johnny hustle
kind of guy doin their research
including Yankees yo Yankees are still
all over them they talked about
Showalter I talked to bottom ur Orioles
they came back as rave reviews I still
think he ends up there I mean other
teams young Clinton White Sox and Gooden
the Phillies are in on him but the he's
a perfect fit for New York you know he
grew up a Yankee fan arises idols mentor
so I just think it's natural for him to
go there do you think Scott Boras thinks
that he runs baseball and I'm being
serious here do you think that he feels
like hey I decide and does he is he the
most important or powerful guy in
baseball
I mean he's totally up there I mean you
know his big thing is these teams are
making so much money go to Bryce Harper
he says that Washington Nationals were
worth about 400 eighty five hundred
million dollars to when Bryce Harper
signed there originally
now that franchise is worth two billion
dollars and he thinks these players are
getting way and are paid with all the
money that's being made out there so he
stomping his speed and in telling
everybody you know not just for his guys
it's like don't just sit back here
don't let these [ __ ] take advantage
because they got plenty of money in
their pockets it's not gonna Bob
Nightingale usatoday baseball columnist
joining us from the winter baseball
meetings in Las Vegas you mentioned the
Dodgers a dark horse for Bryce Harper
are they willing are they willing to pay
more than Philadelphia no I don't think
anybody is you know since Andrew Freeman
wins at Dodgers they haven't signed a
free agent yet you know worth more than
95 million dollars so this would be a
big step for them obviously huge star
you know Bryce Harper's one of those
guys he sells tickets being you know the
Dodgers gonna sell that place out most
of times anyway so I'm not sure how much
value he's going to add to that
franchise
just a lot of value on that field but it
feels like the Dodgers are gonna try to
move yasiel Puig
Cody Bellinger I believe some of the
reports said that what you're hearing
out there as soon as the mouth elders
you know Matt Kemp I'm not sure about
Bellinger I think that'd be a tough one
for them to swallow and they would love
to get you know Corey Kluber sand
Cleveland Indians and the catcher JT
Realmuto from the Marlins
but yeah declare some elf children out
you know there-there's a hole right
there for Bryce Harper what about Noah
syndergaard there was talk that maybe
the Yankees would be able to pick him up
in the meds the Yankees are closing in
Jay Happ right sure how realistic that
word was the Miami Marlins actually
laughed it off and since the first we
heard of a three-way deal but you know
with all those reports it was you know
the miskeen Realmuto the Yankees getting
syndergaard you know what were the
Marlins getting you know bag of balls
you know so we talked about the Marlins
it sounded great and I think it's just
another example of them the Mets being
very aggressive this winter very
aggressive as Mike Trout ever been
chopped
no no I don't think he ever will be
it was always talking about Mike Trout
being a free agent in two years I'll be
shocked gave her loose leaves Anaheim I
think he's very very happy very
comfortable playing for the angels
yeah we used to go out looking for the
spotlight or anything like that very
comfortable so I think they lock him up
before he ever becomes a free agent okay
when they lock him up will he get paid
more than Bryce Harper no I just in a
sense Dan you'll be older I don't see it
but you don't say if you're Mike Trout
setback in NC and certain you can make
the case because he's and you know he's
the best player in baseball in better
numbers I'm just not sure of the Angels
you know it's particularly like I don't
guy gonna go over 400 million dollars
for Mike Trout get some sleep Bob we
appreciate your time it's Bob
nightingale USA Today baseball columnist
for more Dan Patrick show too
ian's channel 239 on directv or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]